Es ist eine absolute weltpremiere
Wenn wir ein paar schritte zurückgehen müssen um zwei personen zusammen komplett auf ein bild zu bekommen ist das bei erde und mond ein
Wenig schwieriger und bisher hatte es noch niemand geschafft
Hatte wohl gemerkt doch jetzt ist es der nasa erstmals gelungen erde und mond
Aus der entfernung zusammen auf ein bild zu bekommen wie es aussieht wie die nasa das hinbekommen hat jetzt bei pixum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
Die erde und mond sind
390.000 kilometer voneinander entfernt damit ist schon einigermaßen klar dass sich ein
Fotograf auch ungefähr in diesem entfernungs bereich befinden muss wenn nicht weiter weg
Um überhaupt ein foto machen zu können in unserem fall ist es eine fotografin und sie heißt
Wo sie riss rex eigentlich ist die sonder auf dem weg zu den asteroiden benno ein asteroid der sich der erde gefährlich
nähern könnte in 150 jahren könnte das der fall sein so etwa zwischen 2169
bis
2199 mit einem eher geringen risiko
2135 kommt er nach den bisherigen berechnungen der erde näher als der mond und könnte dann durch die gravitation von erde und mond
auf diesen kollisionskurs gebracht werden trotz des geringen risikos
Ist er einer der gefährlichsten bekannten asteroiden?
Bekannt ist hier entscheidend denn nachuntersuchungen krachen jedes jahr zwei größere hast du ihnen auf der erde
meistens in entlegenen gebieten oder in einem einschlag winkel wie in china bis
2013 der nur sachschaden verursacht über venlo will die nasa jetzt mehr wissen und zwar damit auch über die entstehung des sonnensystems
Und deshalb hat sie die sonde zu ihm geschickt er ist ein ideales untersuchungsobjekt 1999 entdeckt ist er mit
192 metern durchmessern auf kurs zur erde und somit relativ nah und sie ihre schränkt soll 2020
bodenproben von dem 62 millionen tonnen schweren brocken nehmen und
2023 zurück zur erde bringen doch jetzt ist wo sie ihre tracks auf seiner 600 50 millionen kilometer langen reise
Zur benno in eine ideale position gekommen um erde und mond auf einem bild festzuhalten 5 millionen und 400
20.000 kilometer vom mond entfernt und 5 millionen
120.000 kilometer von der erde klick das foto wurde schon
Im oktober 2017 geschossen aber erst jetzt so berechnet dass es auch vernünftig aussieht die beiden himmelskörper sind nämlich
Unterschiedlich hell und so musste das bild mehrmals gemacht werden und dann zusammen gerechnet werden wie bei einer hdr
Aufnahme also einer high dynamic range aufnahme und voila hier ist es der absolute wahnsinn
vielleicht lasse ich mir mal ein poster oder vom machen die nase fotos kann man ja ganz einfach und erlaubt herunterladen und belichten lassen
Mal sehen ich habe ja noch
Als von der ss was meint ihr solche die man hinter mir hier aufhängen ein kleiner depotwechsel schreibe es in die kommentare
Und wenn er auf dem laufenden zur benno mission bleiben wollt dieses jahr
Erreicht die sonde bereits den asteroiden bringt mehr hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen ich den
Genau auf die glocke und dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit und dafür
Draufklicken hast du ihn und bedrohen die erde jederzeit da gibt es mehr infos zu dem ständigen einschläge von asteroiden auf der erde
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran